hi my name is markiplier and welcome
back to baldies basics this game with
this guy and that ruler that's gonna fit
somewhere in me anyway we're gonna try
some of the challenge modes because it
was weird we did speedy at the end of
the last episode if you didn't see the
last episode gut don't go watch it why
are you here
don't you watch all my videos why not
what are you doing with your life
besides wasting it on watching me it was
fun just to give you a little taste in
case you didn't see yeah it's a little
like this I cannot I cannot I cannot I
can't I cannot there's no way oh my yo D
oh wow oh that's not good I'm gonna run
outta run oh god oh god oh god there was
nothing in here well there was something
in here did I get that oh oh
okay so that's that game alright so I'm
gonna try some other ones because that
seems horrible and why would I subject
myself to that ooh my hair is so fluffy
can you believe this is nothing to do
with this and no one cares but my mom
sent me a shampoo and she would be very
happy to know that I used this she was
very very very interested in me actually
using the said shampoo so mom if you're
watching this I used it and look how
poofy my hair is so goddamn poofy thank
you mom for the lovely shampoo I
appreciate it I big preesh big preesh
what was this one genius oh yeah how you
doing it's like a tack on Titan except
me and Baldy wow it really it really
Yanks you okay
yeah wolf I'm going for it baby
Oh - oh if I do - Oh interesting
interesting
Oh best strats Oh big boy strats it
really is like attack on Titan now you
cannot beat me sweepy man I found my
first door wait stop grab it and I got
and we're leaving and we're leaving and
we're leaving this what do you want for
me don't take my grapple
you stock yeah
Oh excellent
wait no that's too far oh no oh it's a
dime in the dead and my end no not here
no pull oh my god
good he's gone now
oh no crap this is tough it's kind of
fun though
not like this kind of fun not the worst
way I've ever had to deal with traveling
go go go go go go go wait no stop no one
left wait what do you mean one who's
left wait what do you what do you mean
one minute left what do you mean one
minute left
wait I don't know where your class is
lady I don't know what your class did I
make it
hi hey teach how's it going I'm gonna
leave now where are these gosh darn
classrooms Paul
no pull Bulbul oh snap bolt oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god this way this way oh
hey see you around buddy
snooze you lose [ __ ] I have no idea
do I have a map oh I do have a map Oh
oh crap oh crap oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god
[Music]
well I'll try that again now was that
was interesting that was very
interesting
I liked that I wasn't very good at it
and I it's it's very difficult to
understand the way of the school but you
know it's pretty cool okay all right ooh
that is helpful that's very helpful
didn't know that I had a map Oh very
violent doesn't need to be oh let me out
let me out let me out
Hey hey sweet pea man goodbye sweet pea
man oh this is where I need to be no no
no this is where I need to be no no no
give me give me give me give me give me
yeah oh behind me
no oh never mind I don't want to go buy
me I decided against it or else circle
round for it you think you can beat me
slappy man answers probably yes yep wait
yes okay
behind me
okay good no no let me out let me out
let me out let me out no no no I don't
know what I'm slapping - oh he's quick
oh well good thing I got this corner
here you snooze I got it and back here
Oh what is this garbage Oh what is this
garbage Oh what is this garbage okay
fast moves pro moves Wow God he was
faster than I thought he would be he
gets real quick grappling hook don't do
nothing comparatively comparitively
grappling hook do nothing okay I'm very
close to beating this I'm gonna give
this one more try and then I'm gonna
give up because I'm a quitter thank
goodness isn't there I don't know where
the map is oh I can move it oh I can oh
hey that's fun I was already there
though so you could not what if I get
all these other ones in time and
technically speaking I don't even need
to go to your what the hell was a
nightmare oh no no no no no I did it
again I did it again overzealous on the
slapping oh my god okay
that's a problem come on what what what
is the problem
oh that's that's where I needed to be
okay you know what
that's fine
where am I Oh No
dead end oh no no no no no no over there
oh there is a big kind of Circle Route
okay I'm just gonna go to miss lady's
class or not no no not like this not
like this not like this oh no no no all
right let's try something else
it's nice tell the-- what is this about
principal principal principal the
principal what does the dirty chalk
eraser do wait but what what do I need
to do I don't know how the dirty jock
eraser works I don't know how it works
I don't know how it works how am I
supposed to know how it works in school
[Music]
that's impossible
how would anyone do that use derby chalk
erasers lockers and your map to avoid
being seen and collects them do I need
to do deep research on what the talk
erasers actually do because I'll do it
here I go doing it I'm doing it I'm
gonna do it
all you cannot see the player principle
of see the thing cannot see the player
breaking the rules
great it still seems impossible all
right let's try it again you know let's
do it again let's let's do it I guess I
hate all of that whatever is happening
there no you don't see nothing you see
nothing you see nothing you see nothing
you see nothing
oh my god so I'm guessing Baldy ain't
moving is the thing I bet baldies not
moving that's the thing he's just in the
detention center okay
you'll never find me oh so you can see
them on the map all that makes it much
easier oh well now it's practically
trivial nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope you can't see me you can't see me
you can't see me you can't see me you
can't see me I'm vaping too hard right
now alright thank you okay you know I'm
gonna go back to speedy I can't do
stealth oh god I'm gonna run a steam oh
no oh no I'm in a club I'm in one of
these you can never find me
[Music]
man these challenge modes
I mean grapple I bet I could get if I
tried aren't enough but it's also like I
don't know if I want to try get good at
that I don't know if that's what I want
with my life I just dunno oh here he
come
here comes that boy Oh dead end really
guerilla around you you suck you suck
you suck big you suck big dong you suck
biggest dong you big dong
you like the big dong in the sucking
they're all where am i he's too fast
what do you do this I've gotten so many
coins help help help help help oh god I
need to get more run a veces st bar got
it put it in my mouth I did it I'm the
best there's another quarter okay so
technically I think I do run four or am
i technically I do think I run a little
faster well never mind we're in trouble
baby okay so I do run a little faster
than him which is great good news for me
excellent news actually
the best news so I like it's just a
trick of keeping my run speed up by
getting more things crammed in my face
oh crap oh crap oh crap oh crap oh crap
oh crap oh crap on the occasion
apparently we shockingly oh that's not
good that's not good that's not good
that's not what you don't want to see
got it no shove it in my mouth yes you
try me try me you loser you big nerd I
don't know where I am there I am I
should have gone Oh interesting
interesting interesting interesting come
here are you taste some of my soda pop
or not okay as soon as I open like a
door he's gonna come barreling down my
way yep there is I'm here you eat my
soda there's nothing you can do here Oh
I need to stand for this
it's some time for me to show my true
potential my true power my ultimate form
yes I have risen to the height of gods
I'm to die for even the camera to
capture Aldi you have met him Baldy you
have met your match oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh random
again yes at a certain point he does
kind of like lose you and forget where
you are and go all weird he like oh oh
oh no you
nikka we'd alright apparently standing
didn't do anything for me standing did
nothing alright then how about endless
it's endless it's endless exactly what
you want from baldies basics to never
end
is there supposed to be like elevator
sounds in this elevator although I guess
sound effects was never know okay got it
oh no not you you horrible demon there
demon hair demon everywhere
I got what is what is that what is the
[Music]
excuse me I needed a freshie refreshing
cold epub locked on target
I get rekt what a pathetic loser do not
don't no no no no no not you
[Applause]
this is a library well I didn't know
there was a library roof
why is a library okay out of all six I
need six six six six six thank you I'm
very good at the math okay where is her
classroom oh that's a lot of time okay
that's good is it just me or does Baldy
not go any farther or faster or faster
farther
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead hey but at least
I hate you all right that's enough
that's enough that's enough for me
that's that's good I'm I'm good I'm good
I'm good enough I'm good all right so
that was ball these basics plus not
really much more game now all right
makes sense cool
good glad thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know we thought down
the comes below and if there's another
big update to this game I'll play lots
of fun fun fun stuff for the whole fun
family here
glad to know baldies still doing good
check out more of all these basics that
I've done in the description or in the
suggestive videos over there and as
always I will see you
[Music]